sur ce plateau hubert coudurier
directeur de l'information du télégramme
bonjour c'est d'être avec nous c'était
en scénario attendu les deux motions de
censure qui sont donc rejeté à
l'assemblée nationale quel enseignement
est ce qu'il faut retirer à chaud comme
ça
bah écoutez on pouvait alors s'étonner
que visage du 49-3 suscite un tel une
telle bronca parce que par le passé il a
été largement utilisé ça fait partie des
outils institutionnels la vème
république manuel valls l'a utilisé à
plusieurs reprises sans parler de michel
rocard
michel rocard n'avait pas la majorité
comme il est avec en marge à genève
alors que c'est vrai aujourd'hui la
république en marche à une majorité
absolue missiles s'effrite
progressivement justement il ya une
députée la république en marshal bangai
o qui a soutenu une motion de censure
ce week-end il ya également le sénateur
des bouches du rhône la république en
marche michel amiel qui a décidé de
quitter le parti présidentiel est ce
qu'il faut y voir une fronde au sein du
parti après alors en disaient qu'il y
ait pas de frondeurs dans ce dans cette
majorité contrairement à l'époque
hollande et c'est vrai que effectivement
ça commence à tanguer parce que il ya
certains clivages idéologiques l'autre
les marcheurs de gauche et de droite
ce qu'il faut voir aussi c'est que en
l'occurrence usage du 49-3 porte sur un
projet extrêmement sensibles qui
touchent au fondement de la société
française et dont certains disaient il
ya quelques années que toucher aux
retraites c'était le meilleur moyen de
faire sauter un gouvernement
donc les gens ont compris que la
fixation du point n'était absolument pas
garanti
par ailleurs certains régimes de
retraite
pacifique qui pourrait être sanctionné
il était en équilibre qui me demandait
rien à personne
par contre à metz a évoqué avocats
experts-comptables également voilà donc
il ya le sentiment quand même d'une
derrière finalement une inspiration qui
se voudrait généreuse et d'une réforme
soit disant social démocrate
il ya beaucoup d'incertitudes beaucoup
d'inquiétudes et finalement la société
française et depuis la sphère des gilets
jaunes dans un climat d'hystérie de
révolte que ce pouvoir n'a pas su
canaliser ou apaisée
il ya quand même une propension de
l'exécutif mc rhodia ont qualifié de
technocratique a jeté de l'huile sur le
feu notamment ailleurs cette affaire des
retraites est loin d'être terminée elle
va passer maintenant au sénat où la
discussion sera sans doute plus calme il
y aura beaucoup moins d'obstruction mais
enfin où des amendements vont être
intégrés même si le projet de loi avait
déjà intégré les amendements notamment
sur la pénibilité que ce côté la cfdt
ensuite ça va revenir devant l'assemblée
ensuite il ya un deuxième projet de loi
organique cette fois et donc on n'est
pas sorti d'affaires on voit que la rue
est à nouveau en train de se mobiliser
donc si vous voulez on est dans un
projet de loi qui peut être fatale
en plus avec le climat des municipales
le soupçon d'avoir utilisé la psychose
du corps d'un virus pour le faire passer
en douce on est dans un quelque chose
qui peut être fatale au gouvernement
macro et l'expérience du fameux en même
temps justement vous avez parlé des de
la fronde sociale
on a parlé des syndicats vous avez
évoqué les gilet jaune également les
les mobilisations qui se sont multipliés
de manière spontanée depuis ce week end
est ce que la rue peut encore avoir un
impact sur cette fameuse réforme des
retraites selon vous la rue ça participe
aussi de l'obstruction parlementaire il
ya un climat social qui n'est pas bon
sur une réforme qui a du mal à passer
qui semble ne pas avoir été vraiment
bien préparé en amont on se demande
aujourd'hui ce qu'a fait jean paul
delevoye qui avait consacré quand même
un an de préparation pour cette réforme
donc le climat la veille des municipales
n'est pas bon et pourrait coûter cher
pourrait coûter cher à la majorité dans
sa volonté de conquérir des
municipalités il ya aussi le rôle du
front national qui n'a pas qui n'a pas
voté la réforme pendant la censure
déposée par les républicains ce qu'ils
considèrent que les républicains vont au
delà du projet de loi puisqu'ils veulent
des mesures de rigueur financière qui
n'ont pas encore été discuté ils ont
voté la censure de la france insoumise
ce qui ajoute à la confusion ambiante
dans le milieu politique français
justement par de confusion il avait
évoqué les municipales pour parler du
calendrier vers quoi est-ce qu'on se
projette on entend ici et là que
l'objectif du gouvernement c'est de
faire passer cette loi d'ici l'été
peut-être même durant l'été quand il y
aura moins d'actualité que les
les travées de l'hémicycle seront encore
un peu plus clairsemés c'est quoi
l'objectif c'est d'avoir derrière un
boulevard jusqu'à la présidentielle de
2000 22 je n'ai pas l'impression que ce
soit un boulevard pour emmanuel macron
ce que je sens c'est qu'il essaie de se
décharger de ceux de ce poids sur son
premier ministre pour pouvoir se
consacrer à autre chose faire de la
politique étrangère des réformes
sociétales et préparer à deux ans de
l'échéance sa campagne de réélection
même s'il n'est absolument pas assuré
aujourd'hui d'être au second tour
donc la question la plus immédiate ça a
été de savoir si les municipales
seraient ou non
repoussés en réalité je pense qu'elles
vont être maintenues même si la campagne
électorale est aujourd'hui un peu en
suspens parce que c'est difficile de
faire campagne sont serrés demain son
toucher les gens dans des espaces
confinés le coronavirus impacte
forcément la campagne des municipales
mais elles se tiendront et simplement
cette dernière question pour revenir sur
le calendrier d'ici cet été
c'est toi qui passeraient donc d'ici cet
été ou cet été quand les tribunes seront
clairsemée à l'hémicycle c'est
envisageable selon vous il ya un
processus parlementaire qui est
relativement compliquée enfin je vous
hais
le sénat a un rôle est bon devant
l'assemblée il ya aussi conseil
constitutionnel si vous ne faites que
sur le deuxième projet de loi organique
qui ne pourront pas utiliser le 49-3
donc ça peut aussi ralentir les
discussions oui l'objectif c'est d'aller
vite maintenant
le cal et le calendrier parlementaire il
a aussi ses lourdeurs et mais l'objectif
reste effectivement d'en finir le plus
vite possible
quelles que soient les oppositions qui
se cristallise et qui se coagulent merci
beaucoup à hubert coudurier d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le directeur de l'information
du télégramme